i changed my party affiliation because i
just don't feel like it's i just
couldn't live with my conscience to be a
democrat anymore after working on the
new book i just felt like it's just
i i have questions about even i mean i'm
sticking with california i'm going to
fight to save california like you but um
i feel like i'm living in like apartheid
south africa or something i just feel
like i'm living in a place that's not
moral and and i
feel really bad and angry about that and
so
yeah
we don't want to move but it is it's a
this is a pretty this state is pretty
terrible
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the president of environmental progress
and author of the new book san francisco
why progressives ruin cities michael
shellenberger welcome back to the reuben
report
thanks for having me dave good to see
you again
so last time that i saw you was about
three years ago and i think it's fair to
say we both considered ourselves
liberals or democrats or something like
that that's why i wanted to have you on
because i thought oh here's someone sort
of on my team who's frustrated with some
of the stuff that i'm frustrated with
flash forward three years
where yet in your little political
journey before we fully get into the
book and everything else
as usual still having trouble with
labels i mean i wrote an essay called
why i am not a progressive
so i'm definitely not a progressive i
can't accept that label anymore i
changed my party affiliation in april
from democrat to no party preference
which is what we call independence in
california
i
you know i wrote i have two books out
lot one last year one this year
apocalypse never in san francisco were
you know i wrote them in part because i
just wanted to sort of articulate what i
believe you know based on reading the
evidence and what my views are because i
think labels are so inadequate
i think some people um some progressives
will call me you know uh conservative or
right-wing lunatic of course
um
you know uh i some a lot of people i
think call me a moderate the huffington
post quoted me as a moderate
um you know as usual as you won't be
surprised to hear i mean there's some
views i have that i think would be
better categorized as liberal than
conservative and some views that would
be better categorized as conservative
and i think there's some things that are
not easy to categorize
you know i should note for the record
that i actually still am registered as a
democrat in cali
but it's a calculated move because i
wanted to be able to vote in the
primaries so that i could vote for
believe it or not for biden in the
primaries so that i could stop bernie so
that that tells you how that sort of
tells you how politics has become so
crazy and the system is so nuts that you
stay in a party to vote against the guy
you're trying to stop the most you know
yeah
yeah for sure i mean and obviously the
state level now we have a you know an
open primary so that you can vote for um
you know you can have two republicans or
two democrats or two independents in the
runoff so but yeah i just honestly
i i changed my party affiliation because
i just don't feel like it's i just
couldn't live with my conscience to be a
democrat anymore after working on the
new book i just felt like it's just
i i have questions about even i mean i'm
sticking with california i'm gonna fight
to save california like you but um
i feel like i'm living in like apartheid
south africa or something i just feel
like i'm living in a place that's not
moral and and i feel really bad and
angry about that and so
yeah um we don't want to move but it is
it's a this is a pretty this state is
pretty terrible i'm on a lot of levels
yeah let's let's sit with that for a
little bit because as you know i fought
really really hard for this recall i
basically was campaigning with larry
elder the results of this thing were a
disaster
now newsom has you know codified mail-in
ballots basically forever we have one
party rule nothing's working which is so
much of what your new book's about
yeah do you have any hope here like i am
really troubling i'm just having trouble
seeing the the hope if i could see some
hope i'd be like yeah i could still stay
and fight but i just don't see that
glimmer i don't see that star in the
distance anymore
yeah i mean i it's dark right now right
and that but i think the darkness is
also means that we just can't see things
and so we should be humble too about our
own inability to to view what might be
out there you know i will say i think
that the election heavily if you believe
the polling i think it did heavily turn
on the covid response
um and i think most people in california
and i don't know you and i might not
agree on this but you know i think most
california supported the status quo view
of kovid i wrote i tweeted something
that i think now is overly pessimistic
about how people voted for the status
quo i don't necessarily think that's
true
you know we have polling data that also
shows high level 75 70 you know 80
support for basically i think the things
the common sense things that i think you
and i will agree that we need to do
about the open air drug scenes what we
euphemistically call homeless
encampments so i do think there is
public support for a lot of the stuff
that we need to change but yeah i mean
we have uh
you know i think we have a leadership
challenge um i
surprised myself and i did feel like i
needed to endorse somebody i ended up
endorsing kevin faulconer in the recall
in general i don't believe in recalls
because i do think you should give the
guy the four years but in this case i
thought the situation on the streets was
so extreme that it merited the recall so
i did endorse the recall and i endorsed
kevin faulconer and
yeah and then i defended you may have
seen i defended um larry elder against
the unconscionable attacks by you know
the
racist antifa woman or i don't know if
she's antifa so don't sue me but the
racist woman in a gorilla mask
throwing an egg at him and just the
unconscionable
uh media coverage by the la times in
particular but really all the state
media
you know clearly
you know
inappropriate i mean i i sort of
flabbergasted still by how terrible and
biased the media coverage was but
yeah i mean i uh with the book and
certainly in a movement that we're
building we have a coalition of groups
including parents of kids killed by
fentanyl including parents whose kids
are addicted to fentanyl and living on
the streets and who want to get their
kids off the street including recovering
addicts uh we are advocating for a
pretty sweeping set of reforms so
but yeah it's it was discouraging so
when you talk to your
liberal lefty friends or just like the
average california type person one of
the things that i'm still amazed now i
do sense a lot of people waking up and
you know i think that the election and
the way they treated larry was a red
pill for a lot of people but still
obviously the results were basically 70
30. so obviously out of the voters
they're down with newsome and whatever
that means
when you talk to some of the lefties
still
like do they think things are going well
here that always seems to be the
confusing part for me like who thinks
things are going well
i no i mean you know my most progressive
friends are the guys i play soccer with
and they don't think it's okay you know
they think it's a big problem
you know part of the reason i wrote san
francisco is because when i would raise
the problems with them including the
fact that the vast majority of people
living on the streets are addicted to
hard drugs or suffering mental illness
they would say to me um
it sounds like you just want to arrest
everybody and so i wrote san francisco
in part to say here's what i want to do
you know here's what i think the plan is
and it's we don't have to choose between
mass homelessness and mass incarceration
there is a role for police there is a
role for laws and law enforcement but
that's not the end of the story and we
don't want to go back to one floor over
the cuckoo's nest but it's unacceptable
to have these you know 100 000 120 000
people living on the streets using hard
drugs a threat to themselves and others
totally unacceptable so no i think that
there's actually high levels of
dissatisfaction i think we are looking
for
leadership whether that's coming from
the civil society level or from the
political level somebody's got to step
up and challenge newsome who obviously
is up for re-election next year so it's
kind of funny you wrote san francisco
obviously about san francisco you happen
to be in venice right now just visiting
i'm in la at the moment so we're only
about a half hour away from each other
um and we wanted to do it in person but
my schedule's a little nuts today uh but
what's going on in venice because it
seems like venice has been completely
destroyed
yeah so you know what we call homeless
encampments is really a euphemism for
what european researchers call open drug
scenes so you know the san francisco
really describes the whole history of
how did we get here but basically we're
in the midst of two overlapping drug
epidemics as you know one the more
famous one is around opioids it started
with the over prescription of opioids in
the early to that early late 90s early
2000s we then
curtailed doctor prescriptions in the
you know around 2010 a lot of people
switched to heroin now a lot of people
are using fentanyl and dying
93 000 people died last year dave from
illicit drugs it's scandalous it's a
moral failing that's almost five times
more people that die from homicides in
the united states
about three times more than die from car
accidents up from 17 000 in the year
2000 so this is a moral crisis it's
disproportionately impacting california
homelessness increased in california 31
over the last 10 years while declining
18 in the rest of the united states
so what we're seeing in venice beach in
the tenderloin neighborhood of san
francisco in skid row in los angeles but
also in the blade neighborhood of
seattle in portland where i just visited
i was just in portland but also in
vancouver
and now we're seeing very similar
situations uh in philadelphia the
kensington neighborhood so these are all
best referred to as open drug scenes
that's i think the right way to think
about them that's the academic word but
you know there's only one way to deal
with them which is that you have to
require people to use shelter you can't
let people camp in public i know that
sounds like a radical idea but that's
not okay
um people if you wanna if there is some
role for providing people with housing
but they should earn it by making
progress on their personal plan towards
recovery from addiction or or taking
control of their psychiatric illnesses
but we need a shelter first policy we
need a treatment first policy the
housing first policy we have has
completely failed it's basically
unethical because it doesn't actually
try to deal with the root of the problem
which is addiction
everything that we do in california is a
band-aid solution so the solution to
venice beach was just to try to put
people in some hotel rooms temporarily
but everybody just ends right back out
on venice beach or in tenderloin or skid
row because we're not willing to deal
with the fundamental problem which is an
addiction crisis right so that's
actually one of the themes of the book
that the progressive and all the cities
you just mentioned are all progressive
cities that they sort of say the right
thing oh we'll put them in hotels they
will be off the street it sort of sounds
right but then you realize that now
they're just doing drugs in hotels and
no one suddenly gets a job or gets their
life in order is that sort of the
biggest theme to
maybe even a little bit of your own
political evolution that progressives
are constantly saying what sounds right
and easy oh we're not going to police
we're not going to worry about drugs
we're not going to do anything about
homes it all sounds like oh we're trying
to be nice to people but the end result
is pretty much everything in your book
yeah i mean this was one of the big
questions which is sort of you know why
do people who claim to care so much
about people of color the poor the
mentally ill the people addicted to hard
drugs why is it that that the
progressives have allowed the situation
to worsen so terribly in california i
debunk all the reasons given people say
we don't spend enough money we spend
more money than anybody and i documented
more money on mental health than any
other state worst outcomes
people say it's because we don't have
enough permanent supportive housing san
francis
san francis
san francisco it's hard to not spend the
title um san francisco uh has more
permanent support of housing per capita
than any other city and has the worst
outcomes
you know what's going on here is that
this all boils down to victim ideology
where there's this idea that we can
categorize some people as victims
that nothing should be asked of victims
everything should be given
including
you know the right to camp in public to
use drugs in public defecate in public
um engage in even violent behaviors with
no consequences
it's um it's specific to the west coast
it's specific to progressive cities
um but it is spreading around the
country and so yeah i mean there's been
various i mean one of the funniest
things i interviewed progressives i
interviewed a lot of progressives for
this book by the way so they're all in
here and i
i have my own you know i worked for
maxine waters to advocate for needle
exchange in the early in the late 90s i
worked for george soros's uh think tanks
um in the late 90s so i and i still
support
you have a progressive pedigree there's
no doubt about it yeah um so they all
talked to me you know everybody talked
to me and you know a lot of them it was
like they would say things to me like
well this really started with reagan you
know and i was like really like how so
you know
they would say reagan let everybody out
of the mental institutions
as governor in truth it was actually
kennedy who got de-institutionalization
started
um reagan
didn't do what he needed to do but it's
hard to blame it on him people claim
that reagan cut the budget for housing
really the budget for housing at the
federal level stayed the same when he
was president it declined very small
amounts
mostly the changes had nothing to do
with him
progressives have been in charge as you
know in california for a really long
time so this is not a problem that they
can put
on anybody else's back this is really
something they have to own and in fact
you know gavin newsom who used to
identify or position himself anyway as a
moderate democrat was the person who
advocated the housing first policies in
by the way it was george w bush who
instinct who is who made that official
federal policy so it's really been a
bipartisan policy to some extent but the
idea that you should just give people
housing with no requirements on behavior
change has been a progressive you know
i've been at the top of the progressive
agenda for 20 years
did you talk to any of the progressives
say in san francisco here in l.a
who you know like chessa bodine or
george gascon these da's who have
decided not to prosecute basic crimes so
or even in new york they're doing things
like this if you jump the turnstile they
won't arrest you so you're incentivizing
people to break the law but you know if
you steal i think it's under 899 dollars
worth of stuff at a store they basically
won't prosecute you so
you could get a playstation five and you
get five games but you take that sixth
game and now you're in trouble did you
like now i get it i get it they feel
like they're helping somebody who might
need to steal a carton of milk or
something like that not even that that
would make it right but do you ever get
a better explanation on stuff that we
all see the videos and we're like geez
we know this is not right
right so this is your what you're
describing is a selective view of
victims so
progressives are really concerned with
victims of the system and they're giving
a pass to
victims of other individuals so to speak
so so you know give an example of it
progressives are very concerned with
people who they feel are being
victimized by police
than people who are being victimized by
other individuals so african americans
are killed at a rate 30 times higher by
other civilians than they are by the
police and yet there's a huge movement
around police killings which you know is
advocating some reforms that i think are
very positive and we should do but
there's basically no movement whatsoever
for reducing homicides
among african-americans more broadly um
what about uh drug addicts on the street
who are often stabbed with machetes by
drug dealers if they don't you know pay
what they owe them that's how it gets
enforced
um
there's just kind of a shrug into the
shoulders by progressives at those
crimes and the drug dealers according to
chesa bodine
most of whom are from honduras not all
but a lot of the in and that's just
particularly san francisco but the
hondurans control the drug trade in san
francisco and chester boudin has said
that their victims the drug dealers are
victims of human trafficking that's not
true by the way but because they're
people of color and they're immigrants
they get put in the category of victims
so what i'm interested what i was
interested in was why the selected
the selective categorization of victims
and what you come up with is that is
that progressives are strictly concerned
with victims of the system and not
concerned with people that are
victimized by others and so you know one
thing was interesting to me i'm working
on a column called the reason they
defend crime is because they're against
capitalism which is that when you find
people defending
um
the shoplifting the complete looting of
walgreens and you know the uh you know
drug stores in california because you
can steal as you mentioned 950 worth of
items without any consequence
the people who will defend that are
socialists who say well walgreens rips
off its workers
so what you find in the book in san
francis san francisco i document
a long history going back of course to
the 60s of antagonism
to the police but to the criminal
justice system more broadly
and this goes back really to
the 19th century radical anarchists and
socialists who viewed crime
as sort of justified
um because it was um you know getting
that you know fighting back against the
man
um and so so that that's where that
selective victimization comes from i i
felt the need to write san francisco
because i think when my soccer my
progressive soccer buddies read it and
you kind of lay out
where is this ideology coming from and
you realize that yeah it's really that
stupid
like it's like you know you get to the
bottom of it you're like wow that dumb
are you like i thought it maybe would be
more sophisticated but it's just that
stupid at bottom and it's all there
there
yeah once you make it explicit i think
it's harder for people to defend it
does it sort of impress you almost i
mean i ask almost all my guesses at this
point it's caused so much destruction
this radical ideology and destroyed so
many institutions literally destroyed
cities it's destroying colleges it's
destroying it's destroying basically the
fabric of american society do you
somehow admire it in some weird perverse
way i mean even in the last couple days
we're holding this interview for a few
days but in the last couple days you
know kirsten cinema got chased into that
bathroom at arizona state university and
i saw an incredible amount of
progressives and progressive news
organizations defending her oh yeah you
can get up in their face which by the
way is exactly what maxine waters has
been on the record saying get in their
face that you almost admire their
absolute relentless pursuit of
destruction
yeah i mean there's and there's a
cunning to it there's a cleverness to
the manipulation of language in
particular i mean just take a simple
word like homelessness i traced the you
know genealogy of this word back it's a
propaganda word um it's always been a
propaganda word designed
to mix together two ex totally different
groups of people one is the proverbial
mother escaping an abusive husband with
her two kids who doesn't have anywhere
to go that night mixing her together
with people suffering from schizophrenia
who are on the streets often addicted to
hard drugs or people that are just
addicted to hard drugs mixing those
populations together deliberately
confusing two groups of people who
require completely different things and
by the way we do a pretty good job
taking care of the mom
escaping the abusive husband she needs
something different than someone with
schizophrenia and that person
schizophrenia needs something different
than someone who's just addicted to
heroin but the word homelessness
suggests that the only response should
be a charitable response when sometimes
you do need to involve law enforcement
to either
make make sure the laws are enforced
and also to compel treatment because
it's not compassionate to let people die
from drug overdose on the street they
should they you know look i don't want
to if someone wants to kill themselves
in the privacy of their own home fine
but we don't allow people to kill
themselves on the street that's not
that's not something that's consistent
with a civilized society so yeah i sort
of i can admire the cunning the
manipulation but there's just something
really sociopathic about all of it i
mean there's a there's a view
i heard a lot of people say things like
our unhoused population and it just gave
me the creeps dude like it was just like
they're not your population like they're
not they're not objects for you to
control these are often people that
you're contributing in their
victimization
out of some hatred of the system
so yeah it's scary dude um
i remember
i remember when i was lefty and they
would always say fam like we're fam and
i hated it because it was like you're
not my family like we may be friends or
a group and we all kind of have common
cause in some of this stuff but like you
also hate family like they hate the
family structure but we're fam because
we have some like ideological cohesion
or something like that
there's a lot of that forced they call
it forced teaming you know that sort of
sense that we're wrong conforming it's
also a lot of menace there if you don't
conform you'll be ostracized and
stigmatized and all the rest so as you
talk about this stuff and as you write
this stuff and go through whatever your
own political evolution is um
you know you're having a similar
experience to what happened with me
which is your i sense you're finding
that people on the right generally
aren't that bad you know you've done
some stuff with with prageru you know
scary dennis prager uh and i think
you've had conversations with ben
shapiro and a couple other people um
how's that been for you and have there
been red lines with those guys that
you've said something that was so
outlandish so crazily left that they
didn't want to talk to you anymore or
didn't want to air something or wanted
to censor something or silence you etc
no i mean that that's that is shocking
right which is that you know if you go
on a conservative tv show your
progressive friends it's just it's so
upsetting to them
that like the friendship is threatened
whereas if you go on a liberal show like
nobody on the right seems to care you
know and so
it's clearly you know i mean this is my
second book i'm writing a trilogy and
the books you know apocalypse never came
out last year san francisco is coming
out next tuesday
i've got a third book in the works and
these are books really about how these
threats to civilization and the
institutions that support civilization
are coming from people in the grip of a
religious fervor there's this is a
fanaticism and it's it's what's at stake
for you know for when you know like you
kind of like so you go on a show with
somebody you don't like like why would
that threaten like a friendship you know
why would that break up you know why
would that be such a threat to somebody
it's because they have so much of their
identities riding on their political
identity so much of themselves around
their political identity so that their
people's politics have become their new
gods new religions and so we're seeing
you know it's interesting because when
new religions form they are more
fanatical and more apocalyptic
than they become over time they start
more extreme so what's scary is that
this is a new you know is that this is a
new religion
that's asserting its control over the
society
we have to push back against it we have
to expose how harmful it is you know
part of the reason i want to write san
francisco was
it's not just the universities you know
that there's there's real victims of
these policies um 93 000 deaths last
year i'm not going to say all of them
are due to these policies but we went
from 17 000 20 years ago to 93 000 last
year that's a lot of dead bodies
what's a uh say a non-progressive city
that's kind of doing this stuff right
like i've bounced around the country i'm
sure you have i went to salt lake city
it was pretty freaking clean everybody
was decent i didn't see homeless people
i didn't see people doing drugs on the
street i was in new york city last week
i have to say it was more open than i
thought it was going to be which was
nice but there were cops on basically
every single corner and almost every
corner was barricaded and there were a
ton i mean around midtown a ton of
people on drugs and people just laying
in the streets
yeah new york has gotten worse for sure
um though really when you say which
cities have done it better than
progressive west coast cities the answer
is all of them basically you know new
york shelters 99 or at least it did
until the pandemic it sheltered 99 of
all of its homeless you know we shelter
about a third in california and it's
very simple um
if you you have to build enough shelters
um the progressive homeless advocates
put it in in quotes have denied funding
for the shelters they've taken money
away from building sufficient shelter
space and put it into this really
expensive you know seven hundred
thousand dollar two million dollar
apartment unit housing which is grossly
insufficient
miami has done a pretty good job um in
terms of dealing with this population
new york did better
i really look at amsterdam in the book
as my model because it's such a
progressive city it's such a liberal
city it's hard to be against it you know
their sex work is basically legal you
can smoke marijuana and go to the van
gogh exhibit
you know it's a very progressive city
but yet there aren't big homeless
encampments and when you talk to them
about how they dealt with it it was
always social workers and police working
together
so it's not like there's any mystery in
terms of how you solve the problem it's
more like why won't we do it and i think
that's where i get to it's really about
victim ideology right so how do we get
the lefties out of this a little bit
you're talking about sort of the
religious fervor sort of a
you know that the ideas are sort of
antithetical to what is actually working
have you figured out a way to make any
headway with them that they generally at
least from where i'm at seem to double
down when things don't work oh yeah it
didn't work not because of what we did
but because of those guys sort of like
your reagan answer from before have you
figured out any tricks in this little
period that you've been doing this
well i don't know if it's a trick but i
do think you have to we have to have a
proper solution to the addiction and
psychiatric crisis which is really what
is driving what we call homelessness
in and this is not to deal with crime
which is a separate issue we could we
could talk about at least not with
homicide but so we've come up in the
book i proposed something called cal
psych
which would be um basically taking over
from the counties which can't deal with
this problem because you know street
addicts are incredibly transient
population they move from city to city
often to escape law enforcement or just
because things go bad
we need a single agency to deal with
this
it needs to be a psychiatric and mental
health response
an addiction response it also would
allow us to have drug treatment
facilities in places like fresno if
you're if you're addicted and breaking
the law in venice beach and you get
arrested and offered to either go to
jail or prison or to go get drug
treatment then you don't there's no
reason to be in venice beach where real
estate values are really high and
expensive it's hard to build something
and go to fresno and do it so when my
progressive friends say what do you want
to do i say i want to do this thing
called cal psych
um you know if anybody should have a
problem with it it should be
conservatives it should be libertarians
and i spend the last the very last few
chapters of san francisco
interviewing the leading conservative
thinkers on this proposal and they all
support it so chris ruffo who's famous
for critical race theory before that he
was a really important researcher on
homelessness and drugs
he is on board with this i interview
a top scholar at manhattan institute
which is an important center right think
tank they're on board with this
um you know republicans have sort of
privately acknowledged that the state
needed to take over psychiatric and
addiction care but it hasn't been
something that has been at the center of
their agenda so my hope is that
some center-right candidate and by the
way it could be a democrat independent
or republican doesn't have to be a
republican
we'll pick up cal psych and run with it
we made some headway with kevin
faulconer in the in the um in the recall
he certainly i think over time started
to understand why you need to have a
single state uh provide this service
but i do think that would be game
changing because i think that starts to
look a lot closer to you know psychiatry
for all universal psychiatry which is
something that progressives should
embrace
and then the only thing that comes along
with it is that you know
if you're going to have psychiatry for
all you can't just go and do your hard
drugs in public there need to be some
consequences as well
that's the when we put that together
with polling we find 70 to 80 support in
fact we found stronger support among
democrats than republicans because so
many republicans felt like
that was already being a little bit too
soft you know that people should just go
to jail
right was there was there any polling on
how things changed over the last two
years not only because of lockdown but
also because of the riots and you know
the riots were getting pretty damn close
to my last house i no longer live there
i'm not sure how much longer i'll live
in this house like that that that
changed we know that california had its
first net loss of population in the
history of the state last year
yeah i haven't seen any change i would
be surprised if the basic attitudes
change because i think the basic
attitudes on this issue towards people
with mental illness people with drug
addictions
are formed from kind of pretty core
liberal or conservative values depending
on how you think about things like human
nature and society you know these issues
of are you a victim of society or a
victim of individuals tends to just be
kind of a core almost unconscious
part of people's thinking
but what i will say i think has changed
is that it is now viewed as a threat to
public um order and public health and
that it's not just you know you see the
encampments everywhere now and so i
think that's had a big impact in terms
of increasing what pollsters call the
salience of the issue when you ask
what's the most important issue facing
california what they say is covid and
then that's number one and number two
they say homelessness
and kovid's gonna you know that's going
to go away or it's going to be dealt
with so
i would say you know if i were advising
someone to challenge gavin newsom i
would say you probably just want to
agree with them on the covid response
that might be hard for conservatives but
i would just agree with them on the
coveted response
and just challenge him on the
homelessness issue because honestly you
could implement much of what he has
promised to do and hasn't done
um you could promise to do that and i
think people would be on board with that
because he's given good rhetoric to a
lot of these things but hasn't had the
kind of software
or um courage to be able to to stand up
against the aclu and the radical left
within the democratic party somebody
that i think embraced a
a treatment first shelter first approach
along with cal psych i think could make
a lot of headway particularly if they
just kind of conceded the issue of covet
which i just think most californians
agree with the status quo on
yeah man i mean i hope you would be
right on that i just think it's so weird
to me how many people here seemingly are
brainwashed even on the cobit stuff and
i'm not sure we were in full agreement
which obviously wouldn't wouldn't matter
to me um you know this that so many
people voted for the guy who was locking
everybody down while he was eating in
the most expensive restaurant in the
state i mean
and the first thing that he did after
getting
you know re-elected or after the recall
failed the first thing he did was
basically get la to institute new new
measures like i just i can't imagine
what it's like being in the brain of
those people
but maybe that's just me
yeah and i think you know i mean you
probably can in the sense that you know
um california's changed a lot of last 20
years you know people are much wealthier
all of us that own you know 65 percent
of voters are homeowners if you own a
home you are like you saw your wealth
increase so dramatically over the last
10 20 years
and you know people are pretty neurotic
man i mean you know you live in l.a i
live in berkeley like people would look
people give me bad looks if i was not
wearing a mask on a nature trail like 10
feet away from them you know there's a
lot of neuroticism that i think
is stronger among so it's a much more
progressive
electorate than it was 10 or 20 years
ago it's a much more neurotic electorate
but i think that that is not necessarily
a i mean that's been
um i think for that's been annoying for
conservatives and even for maybe
moderates like myself on covet issues
because i do think kids should have gone
back to school you know right away
but i do think that that neuroticism
and the concern around public health and
the concern around public order does
favor change when it comes to dealing
with the open drug scenes that we call
homeless encampments you mentioned um
sort of the religious fervor behind this
earlier and as you're talking about the
neuroticism now it seems to me that if
you have this sort of secular idea on
steroids this you know government's
going to do everything on steroids
it leads to this sort of crazy
neuroticism because government can't
solve all of your problems and you're
constantly looking to it as you would
god or whatever it is that you believe
in i'm wondering if that tracks with
where you're at sort of politically too
because i've seen a bunch of my liberal
friends that are on a similar trajectory
as me that now are either believers that
weren't believers or are at least
questioning or something along those
lines
oh yeah for sure you know and i think
that like you know i want to distinguish
between
the progressive activists who are based
have the victim ideology and control
policy to some extent a large extent at
the at the state level in terms of
housing first aclu those folks want to
distinguish from them and you know say
my hairdresser who voted for bernie
sanders who also is upset about the
homeless situation the open drug scenes
she's more in that 70 to 80 percent that
i think would favor
a more balanced response of both carrots
and sticks in terms of a shelter first
treatment first approach rather than a
housing first approach
so i think the challenge again i think
it's a there is a leadership problem i
mean you need to have somebody who can
articulate that vision
and explain it to people because you
know when you get people
in a conversation like a focus group
rather than in like an ins you know if
you're using type 2 thinking slow
thinking rather than fast thinking i
think people are more
attentive to the need for a balance that
it's you shouldn't just be able to you
we still have a very deep reciprocity
you know motivation which is that if you
give somebody something you should
expect something in return progressives
are violating that in this idea of you
just giving street addicts anything they
want and not asking for public order and
public behavior in return so that seems
to me that's the soft underbelly of the
progressive agenda in california
honestly i think it's the soft
underbelly of democrats nationwide i
think republicans should be doing a lot
more with it which is that you know here
this big package this big budget package
is going to give what a couple more
years of college education some child
care credits but what's it doing about
like the most important
cause of death accidental cause of death
i mean here the fda finally issued a one
pill can kill
advisory but i mean like we're seeing
you know kids are kids who experiment
with thinking they're taking a half a
percocet buying it from a dealer on
snapchat or dying in their bedrooms
being found by their parents i mean this
is michael k williams the great actor
from the wire who died from fennel
poisoning
prince tom petty i mean you know
fentanyl changes everything in terms of
this is not just an addiction problem
we're now dealing with with active
poisoning and democrats are just not to
be found
anywhere i'm dealing with this so i do
think there is room for maneuver i do
think it's a dark moment right now but
there's so much chaos in the system in
the last four years we've seen that that
something is going to change that that
the system can't maintain its
instability for for many more years i
think republicans are moving in a lot of
the issues that you and i i think
probably had concerns with republicans
over 10 or 20 years or just not issues
anymore you know
i see the progress that's you know like
one of the characters in my book
um is harvey milk the gay rights leader
um i asked my my publisher i was like
are my conservative readers gonna have a
problem with harvey milk and he was like
no i mean it's like that issue's gone so
a lot of the social issues seem to be
taking moving to the background and we
see
new issues coming to the forefront that
i do think open up possibilities for
some challenge to progressive orthodoxy
you know it's interesting as you were
mentioning that i may have told you this
story three years ago but when i had
interviewed david horowitz the first
time and david horowitz was sort of the
original why i left the left guy he told
a story about how you know he was
marxist his whole life a leftist his
parents were communists and then in 1984
he liked reagan during the re-election
so he says you know basically i'm
leaving the left and then he told me
this story about how
in new york at the peak of the aids
crisis that all of the public health
officials who basically they were
lefties it was run by mostly democrats
that they all knew that it was emanating
from the gay bath houses like they just
knew people were doing drugs there they
were having unprotected sex and they
knew it was all coming from there and
they knew that all of these people young
people were dying every day hundreds and
thousands were dying and that the
conservatives who had really no power
the republicans in new york city came in
and said well okay we got to close the
bath houses that's how we have to do
something here and it was the democrats
who said no because they didn't want to
infringe on you know on those people's
lifestyle to be thought and they called
direct they called them homophobes
basically anyway i'm just reminded of
that because it's so consistent with
everything that you're saying here
yeah because they were because they were
the victimization or the spread the
spread of hiv aids was occurring at the
individual level rather than something
being imposed by the system and so
yeah i think that you have to remember
progressives start from the point of
view that the system is evil you know
and it's basically a russowing idea that
the individual is innocent and good and
that the society is what's corrupting
and conservatives just to really dumb it
down to kind of big crayon level and
conservatives are more like humans are
fallen and
and um and society is what keeps us on
the straight and narrow and i think
that's still very much alive here it's
why it's why we allow people to be
killed by drug dealers
um killed by civilians but we you know
are
you know just everything changes when
people are perceived as being victimized
by the state right like literally if you
if you bring up black on black crime
they'll tell you you're a racist i mean
that's your point yeah
yeah and i mean here's the interesting
thing and i i find i i i'm interested in
hearing your view of it too i mean
to declare all black people victims
that's totally racist and the idea that
all white people are privileged is also
racist and when you really kind of
listen to it for a minute you go so let
me get this straight you're saying that
all white people are privileged and all
black people are victims
and that you think that's not racist
it's the most racist thing
victimology is actually bigger than that
of course it's encompasses that kind of
racism but it also suggests
that a whole set of other people are
basically that people are powerless you
know that people that you put in the
category of victims are powerless and
therefore
and one of the consequences of course is
it is that we shouldn't do anything to
prevent them from being victimized
because doing so would only exacerbate
the victimization
one of the
sorry go ahead well you no no you know
my feelings on this but i'll tell you
this look i have larry elder coming to
my house for dinner tonight larry elder
born in south central dad was a janitor
does not view himself as a victim and is
not a victim and i have one of my best
friends from childhood whose son right
now who's white
which it doesn't matter other than for
the purposes of this story his son is
hooked on fentanyl right now and and he
you know and it's like he grew up
privileged and that his dad had a job so
it's like none of this makes any sense
i'll give you you know i'll tell you
something i was i've been obsessed with
this um with one of the fathers of
cognitive behavioral therapy named
victor frankel who's famous because he
wrote a book called man search for
meaning he's one of the original
humanistics humanistic psychologists of
the 1960s
his whole book man's search for mean is
about how he survived the concentration
camps
under the nazis and he did so by
changing his mentality and getting a
goal and his goal was you know survive
the concentration camps um uh
find my wife and parents
and read and write a book about the
experience and he so his whole thing was
mentality mentality mentality forget
about how bad the situation is mentality
is everything
and he was loved by progressives in the
60s victor frankel's book man searched
for me and sold like 10 million copies
it's this incredibly i during the
pandemic when i was in some dark moments
i'd watch like these five minute youtube
videos of viktor frankl talking
and suddenly i felt enthusiastic about
life
and and yet if you take viktor frankl's
core message
of empowerment which i think is the very
elder message you know that you're
describing as well
which is that you can change your life
you can take control and responsibly
your life but if but but somehow
progressives said that's fine for
self-help but in politics it's blaming
the victim
to suggest that people have control over
their lives to suggest that people have
responsibility and agency and
empowerment was viewed as blaming the
victim and boy what a disservice
and and what a destructive view this
idea that you should categorize people
as victims and suggest they're powerless
well that's why i always say it's
anti-human actually because the one
thing that separates us from the animals
is our re is our ability to logic and
reason and dream and pursue and have
passion for something and build that was
a lot of things that i combined into one
thing but like that's the thing that's
the thing and they're and they're saying
no it's not yours it's ours to somehow
give to you
and that seems to me um in terms of uh
fighting back against the radical left
and the dehumanization that you're
describing and the disempowerment that
seems to me to be the soft underbelly as
well we i think have a natural instinct
to not want to perceive ourselves as
victims in fact in the book i describe a
fair amount of uh homeless guys will
confess that they were just playing the
victim but they don't actually perceive
them homeless guys living in the streets
don't actually perceive themselves as
victims and i think in part because it's
like that's a terrible way to live it's
a it's it's a depressive way to live and
it's hard to sustain it
they might pretend that for a bit but i
think that really you're on to something
really powerful here which is and i
think that you know all of your work
honestly dave has been really um
uh creative and productive when you're
talking about this question of of
psychological health that the extension
of psychological health in one's own
life in politics should be one of
empowerment
i don't think that means that um you
know i think when it comes to things
like healthcare that we still may need a
universal psychiatric program but it has
to be paired with with this idea that
people are capable of taking
responsibility for their lives
even people frankly with disabilities
and addictions and in all sorts of
terrible circumstances all the more
reason that they should be empowered to
take power and responsibility for their
lives and of course that that's the
irony because as i've become say more
libertarian in general and people say
well you don't care about these people
or something like that now first off
it's it's not an honest statement
because it's like they're usually doing
nothing for them either they're just
screaming about it they're pretending or
they want the state to do it but they're
pretending but i think even bigger than
that is sort of like well if any of the
stuff worked if you gave me policies
that worked some of the things you're
describing here then it's like oh we
should fund those things properly but if
you consistently show me things that
don't work and keep people trapped in
this cycle of poverty and everything
else well then yeah i don't need my
money going to it it's not even about
money i just don't need
that's not how society should operate
that's right and if i had any if i had
any um if any advice comes out of san
francisco for libertarians and for the
right it's just that we should lead with
what we want to do which is i think
that's why i sort of say i want the
modified i want to modify dutch i just
want to do what the dutch do
i mean and why do i want to do what the
dutch do it's not out of some
ideological predisposition it's because
it works so darn well you know there's
nobody on this there's hardly anybody on
the street very few people on the street
um marijuana is basically decriminalized
um
you know but they've also got the most
humane treatment of the mentally ill the
most humane treatment of addicts it's
exactly what you said it's but it's got
a balance we've got to restore some
balance here and i think that's the kind
of thing that my progressive soccer
buddies and my hairdresser and the folks
that voted for bernie i think that's
what the vast majority of them want they
just want to see some balance restored
that if we're going to give something we
should get something in return yeah you
know it's interesting on the sort of be
careful what you ask for thing like i'm
completely for legalizing medical and
well medical certainly and recreational
marijuana and some psychedelics and
things like that but i will tell you
when i was in new york last week a lot
of the street corners that used to smell
like urine they smell like weed i'm
actually not sure if that's good
you know
it just is what it is i suppose
no i actually i appreciate you saying
that i have some real concerns about
what we might call the idw's um
excitement about psychedelics
um it's showing up on my instagram
page that i can take psychedelics and
there's no downside to them
i've become much more sensitive to that
i've always been an advocate of
decriminalizing marijuana um my view is
that we have amazing drugs available um
to us more than ever in history and
they're very powerful and
they're different from one the
people have to
we have more complexity of drugs
drugs are different from one another
nobody overdoses from marijuana but a
little bit of fentanyl can kill you okay
so these are two drugs but you can abuse
marijuana and marijuana can have really
harmful impacts
and so this is again where you just have
to have a system of care
you know i think if you're you know we
know that ecstasy mdma um works well
with victims of extreme trauma who are
having a hard time overcoming their ptsd
there's some evidence that some of the
other psychedelics have some benefit um
as antidepressants they need to be done
under supervised circumstances i mean
this is wild west out here um
you know uh and again i think this has
been a traditional sensitive issue both
for you know right libertarians but also
for left libertarians like aclu but i'm
i i kind of go i don't know what the
problem is of having psychiatry involved
in helping to guide people's
um you know use of those drugs because
maybe they'll have some benefit for
people or maybe they won't maybe they
would be better off taking an ssri you
know maybe medical marijuana is better
for some people than an ssri but you do
need some kind of professional
care involved in that or i think you
just end up with you know 120 000 people
on the streets addicted to hard drugs
the best line since you mentioned the
idw the best line that i heard on
psychedelics was when i was on tour with
jordan people would often ask in the q a
what do you think about psychedelics
what do you think about magic mushrooms
and his answer was always the same be
wary of unearned wisdom
and i always i always thought that was
like you kind of said it all pretty
succinctly
absolutely yeah and i think we
underemphasize things that are probably
more boring but at least for me
personally and my own mental health have
been much more important like exercise
like you know it's like it's so boring
and everyone gets sick of me here
talking about but i'm kind of like if i
don't exercise like a hard exercise
every other day then i'm just not right
mentally and i think there's just a lot
of people where i'm like i see people
looking for a kind of medicine or
something to take rather than doing
other things that are much better for
self-care i that's actually where i
wanted to to end this with you um that
as you've been on this journey i wonder
just your life in general whether it's
your relationships
physical body mental spiritual i can say
my life is significantly
better on all fronts you know like
confronting
the ideologies that i had to break
through and let go of some things and
and traverse that new territory and find
out that people i thought were scary
aren't that scary and some of the things
that i believe weren't and then that
translated into actually taking better
care of myself physically mentally
spiritually everything else i sense
you're kind of in a similar spot
i i am thank you for asking and i really
appreciate how you've shared your own
personal journey with your videos over
the years i found it really
um inspiring and brave because i know
it's not easy to do to share some of
these things it's really not easy for me
yeah i mean just like you said i um
i basically couldn't finish apocalypse
never until i came back to my faith
until i felt like
um until i stopped being embarrassed
about my faith and believing actually
that it was
okay for my psychological health to have
faith in fact that it was quite
important to it i also stopped drinking
three years ago um
almost exactly and it was one of the
best decisions i ever made
for my life and it was um you know i i i
think about how to talk about it and i
really i didn't in the end i decided not
to write about that in san francisco
which is nice that you asked about it
because i felt like i didn't want to
compare my situation to something of
people on the street because that's a
really different situation
but it did make my life better and it
was what i needed to do because i wasn't
able to get control of my drinking in a
moderate way
so and for sure
you know all the things that you hear
really matter um
family
faith
sobriety
and then i would just add exercise
have been really important for me
in dealing with tough times
crazy right wing stuff huh
mike it was good seeing you we will do
this in person next time i promise and
uh good luck with the book we're going
to link to it down below and i'll talk
to you soon it's great to see you again
thanks dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell